سبعة عمال في حانة فلوريدا
ومجموعة من 16
صديقًا خرجوا لقضاء ليلة ممتعة
جميعهم ثبتت
إصابتهم بفيروس كورونا ، كانت إريكا كريسب
واحدة منهم كانت مريضة لمدة أسبوع
لكنها هنا مع اثنين من هؤلاء
الأصدقاء كات لايتون
ودارا  هل هو حلو أم عرق ،
كل شيء جيد أن يكون لديك آه الآن ،
لا أريد أن يتعرق أي منكم ، هذه
ليست واحدة من هذه الجلسات ،
أنا سعيد لأنك تشعر بتحسن
أنك شاب ،
آه الحمد لله لم تفعل  لم أتعرض للطريقة التي
فعلت بها ، أردت فقط أن أعطي كل واحد
منكم بسرعة فرصة لمشاركة
ما تشعر به الآن بعد هذه التجربة ،
إريكا
بدءًا منكم ، أعلم أنه لم يكن لدى أي شخص أقنعة كانت
مزدحمة هناك تمامًا مثل شريط عادي
لماذا تعتقد  كان من الجيد القيام بذلك
بهذه الطريقة وماذا تعتقد الآن
أعتقد أنه في ذلك الوقت كان بعيدًا عن
الأنظار
لم نكن نعرف أي شخص لديه الأمر
شخصيًا أم
محافظ البلدية ، والجميع يقول إنه من الجيد
أن نخرج ، إنه  عيد ميلاد صديق
كان من الخطأ شعورك حيال
ذلك الآن أنت  قل إنه خطأ ، ما
الذي تريد أن يعتقد الناس
أنني أحمق أنه من المبكر
جدًا أنه من الواضح أنك تعلم أننا مرضنا بشدة على الفور تقريبًا في
غضون أيام ، لذلك
يبدو أن الواعظ الأكثر فاعلية
هو التحول
الآن يمكنك إخبار الناس الذين أعرفهم  لماذا
تعتقد أنها ليست مشكلة كبيرة
أه تعلم مني على الأقل من الآن ، شكرًا
لك على المضي قدمًا والقيام بهذا ،
أعلم أن
هذه ليست الطريقة التي أردت أن تظهر بها
لأول مرة في كومو برايم تايم ولكن شكرًا لك
أه على القيام بذلك كات ليتون أه أنت
هل كنت هناك أيضًا أه كان لديك مجموعة مختلفة قليلاً من
الأعراض التي كانت لديك من ذلك لا توجد رائحة ولا
طعم متنوع
أم نعم كيف تشعر الآن
وكيف تغيرت وجهة نظرك
أنا أشعر أنني بخير حقًا أنا تعرف
ذلك  من الغريب جدًا أن تكون قادرًا على
التنفس ولكن لا تشم رائحتك ، فأنت تعرف
أشياءك المفضلة ولكن من الغريب نوعًا ما أن
تشتكي من أشياء كهذه في
الوقت الحالي ،
لكن تجربتي هي بالتأكيد
أنك تعرف بالطبع أننا نأسف لأننا
هل نفعل f
أحمق ثعبان البحر يقف هناك أمام كل هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين عرفنا أننا كنا ندفعها وأنت تعرف لا ، إنه أمر ساحق بعض الشيء ، أعتقد أن نكون متقدمين على هذا ولكننا نريد حقًا رفع مستوى الوعي الذي نريد السماح به استفد من ذلك وأخبر الناس أنك تعرف أنه ليس جاهزًا حقًا لكيفية ما اعتقدنا أنه جاهز لذلك ، إنه من السابق لأوانه عندما أدركت أنك لم تكن على ما يرام ، ما الذي حدث في ذهنك من جائحة عالمي يحدث وأشعر بالمرض ، كنت أشعر بالخوف قليلاً من التوتر وتلقيت رسالة نصية مفادها أن أصدقائي كانوا مجرد طفرة إيجابية طفرة إيجابية ، كانت الطفرة الإيجابية العودة إلى الوراء غامرة قليلاً إذا مرض أي شخص. ليس على حد علمي ، أعتقد أن جميع أعراضنا كانت معتدلة إلى حد ما ، وأعتقد أن واحدًا أو اثنين منا كان يعاني من أعراض تشبه أعراض الأنفلونزا ، ونحن نحب الاستلقاء في السرير ولكن في معظم الأحيان ، من ذوي الأعراض الخفيفة جدا  أمهات
طوال
الوقت بأكمله يساوي أربعة أو خمسة أيام
ثم بدأ الأمر في
التحسن نعم نعم سيدي نعم إيريكا أعلم أنه كان
هناك مجموعة مكونة من 16 فردًا منكم
مرض الجميع كل واحد
منا وهل سمعت أه قصص عن الناس
الذين لم يكونوا جزءًا من مجموعتك
يمرضون ، هل يعتقد أي شخص أنه كان
شيئًا يتعلق بهذا المكان أو تعتقد
أنه
يفعل الكثير في وقت قريب جدًا لا نعم ، لقد قيل لي
أن كل هذا تم طرحه للجمهور قبل أيام
قليلة  لقد تم إرسال الرسائل والملاكم من
قبل
الغرباء الذين كانوا
هناك في نفس عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ، الجمعة
والسبت والأحد ،
وهم الآن مرضى للغاية ، لذا لم تكن
مجموعتنا فقط ،
بل كان هناك مكان واحد مشترك كان
المكان الوحيد
حتى أنهم يهتفون باسمه
وحوت صفارات الإنذار ،
هذا تكريم
للدكتور ميغيل أنجل بيريز ألفارادو ، الطبيب الذي عمل في
سيارة إسعاف عامة في مدينة المكسيك
، توفي الشهر الماضي بسبب كوفيد 19.
ذ
لقد كان قلقًا من الفيروس الذي تخبرنا به زوجته نانسي
لأنه كان يعلم أن ظروف عمله
لم تكن آمنة ، أخبرها الدكتور بيريز أنه لم يتم
تزويده بمعدات الحماية المناسبة
في العمل
وأنه ليس وحده سبعة مسعفين
وطبيب يعمل في سيارات الإسعاف العامة
أخبرنا نفس الشيء هنا يوضح المرء كيف
يمكن رش الماء من
خلال المآزر التي حصلوا عليها من
الشريط اللاصق ، فمن المهم الآن أن يستخدموه
لإصلاح الثقوب في
بدلاتهم ولصق أكياس القمامة لمحاولة
عزل حالات الطمع داخل سيارات الإسعاف الخاصة بهم
يتحدث بدون الكشف عن هويته خوفًا من فقدان
وظيفته ، يقول هذا المسعف إنه
كان عليه وزملاؤه شراء
معدات السلامة الخاصة بهم ، ويقول
إنهم يرسلوننا إلى حرب بدون
أي شيء ، ولا ترسل رجل إطفاء
إلى حريق بدون حماية ،
لذلك هذا هو  القناع الذي يقول المسعف
الذي نتحدث إليه أن الحكومة
أصدرت
له ولست بحاجة إلى أن تكون خبيرًا طبيًا
لتفهم أن هذا
لا يمنحه نوع الحماية
التي يحتاجها.  قال ics الذين تحدثنا إليهم للعمل
في قسمين من وزارة الصحة المكسيكية ،
كلا القسمين ، إن جميع المسعفين
لديهم بيانات الإمدادات المطلوبة
التي يبدو أنها
غير صحيحة
بشكل واضح خاصة عندما ترى كيف من
المفترض أن يتم ذلك ، لقد أمضينا الليلة
مؤخرًا مع طاقم سيارة إسعاف الصليب الأحمر
متطوعون من القطاع الخاص لديهم جميع
المعدات المناسبة وحتى
وحدات مرغوبة محددة
وهذا أمر ضروري لأن أسوأ
وباء المكسيك
يحدث الآن في وردية عمل مدتها 12 ساعة ، وكان هناك
12 مكالمة مرغوبة
وأحيانًا كنا متأخرين جدًا لذا تلقينا
هذه المكالمة  منذ ما يزيد قليلاً عن 20 دقيقة
الآن
وقد وصلنا للتو إلى مكان الحادث وفي ذلك
الوقت
كانت الضحية البالغة من العمر 43 عامًا قد
ماتت بالفعل
بسبب الأعراض التي تتوافق مع الطمع 19.
والوصول إلى المرضى الذين لا يزالون على قيد الحياة
لم يكن دائمًا مهمًا في النهاية
ماريا البالغة من العمر 72 عامًا  تم أخذ إيزابيل كروز هيرنانديز
من شقتها
ونقلها مباشرة إلى المستشفى
أخبرنا ابنها أنها توفيت منذ ذلك الحين
بعد كل يوم مرهق.
يتم رش كل من الشاحنات والمسعفين من
الرأس إلى أخمص القدمين بمطهر خاص
في الوحدات التي تديرها الحكومة ، ويقول المسعفون
إنهم يحاولون تطهير اثنين
مرة أخرى بالإمدادات التي اشتروها
بأنفسهم ، هل أنت خائف نسأل
دائمًا إنه يقول إنك لا تنام خائفًا
على نفسي خائفًا من  أصاب
عائلتي وخائفًا من أن ينتهي به الأمر مثل الدكتور بيريز
بعد يومين من ذهابه إلى المستشفى
، أرسل رسالة نصية إلى زوجته أخيرًا
، قال لي كن حذرًا ، فأنا أحبك كل ذلك
كان آخر مرة تحدثنا فيها بعد
ثمانية أيام ، مات الدكتور بيريز
مات  الأنهار سي إن إن مكسيكو سيتي
، ليس الأمر كما لو أنك لم تسمع بهذا
قبل مسؤولي الصحة الذين يحثون
الجميع على الحصول على لقاح الأنفلونزا ، لكن
مدير مراكز
السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها
يقول إن الآن مهم بشكل خاص
للتطعيم ضد الأنفلونزا
يقول الدكتور روبرت ريدفيلد إذا  تحدث موجة ثانية
من فيروس كورونا عندما يبدأ موسم الإنفلونزا ،
فقد يؤدي ذلك إلى إجهاد المستشفيات حقًا ، ولكن إذا حصل
المزيد من الأشخاص على لقاح الإنفلونزا ،
فقد يخفف ذلك من إجهاد محتمل.  ن
مصادر يقول إن حوالي 47 في المائة فقط
من الأمريكيين يستفيدون من لقاح الإنفلونزا ،
لكنه يأمل أن يرى الجمهور أنه
طريقة رئيسية يمكنهم من خلالها مساعدة هذه الأمة في
تجاوز الخريف ،
ولم يتم الإبلاغ عن جميع حالات الإنفلونزا ولكن
تقديرات مركز السيطرة على الأمراض (CDC) تبدأ
من الأول من أكتوبر  من عام 2019 حتى 4 أبريل
2020 ، كان هناك ما يصل إلى 56 مليون
حالة إصابة بالأنفلونزا مع ما يصل إلى 62000
حالة وفاة
أثناء اكتشاف الأنفلونزا على مدار العام
في الولايات المتحدة ، تعد فيروسات الأنفلونزا الأكثر شيوعًا
خلال فصلي الخريف
والشتاء في اللحظة الصحية الحالية أنا
ماندي غيثر